as a mother it was very very tough
a nightmare
he wanted to go and help and I totally
got all that
but
I didn't like this feeling
and I didn't expect it to still be so
Raw
feeling SoDo after it
they thought their boy might not return
home from the front line in Ukraine
but Douglas did make it back to the
family farm in Southwest Scotland
the helicopters are the worst and you'll
hear the
by this point you're curled up the wall
going not today please not today
he had no military training but still
decided he had to go I was sat here
actually drinking a beer watching
Netflix uh made my decision
packed up the stuff and
left my job enough I went
you like I'm young enough I can
contribute to a better world
he was known as soap a video game
character who was now in the reality of
trench warfare they chilled the hell out
of us you're sending a hole in the
ground which is
the wrong hat there's no coming over
we've seen it
down for a few of our guys
I think we get we get to come home
but they don't
they don't
the sadness is Blended with the
exhilaration of liberating Villages that
have been occupied by Russians you know
there's like people lined up in the
streets with table tops selling
vegetables there's people starting to
build houses
to actually see that it just made Evelyn
more boil you tell me that you were
considering whether you go back I hang
off
packed and unpack that bag
several different times
they'll go back to the front they'll do
something else do it
yeah so it's it's and then the effect on
the family and friends it's a
quite a dilemma
I think it would be a suicide mission if
he did go back to Ukraine I really do
mentally and physically for them he's
been you know he's been short out nearly
killed concussion
um the list was on I mean
we're lucky we've got Douglas Park but
in Ukraine there's a lot of people that
won't be coming back
this war which became his war is far
from over
Tom Parmenter Sky News